my name is freya bass and i own bugs
more a handbag restoration company in
sydney australia today i'm going to walk
you through how i restore a 4 000 chanel
vanity case
typical of a bag of this age the lining
is disintegrating it is a coated fabric
we also have wear and tear to the outer
corners
this bag was purchased 10 years ago for
1500 us dollars it is today worth
between 3 000 and 5 000
so in its restored state it will be
worth more towards five thousand dollars
to begin the process i'm going to remove
the strap from the bag so i'm going to
do this using some small pliers to
gently remove the chain from the link
the strap is very worn so there is color
wear dirt build up and the metal work is
tarnished i'm then going to take quick
unpick and undo the stitches at the end
of the chain
i now need to unthread the leather
through the chain so that it's
completely separated from the metal work
[Music]
now i fully remove the leather from the
chain i'm going to clean the strap
so the leather strap will just be
cleaned initially with foam cleaner
so i'm doing this with a horse hair hide
brush which is nice and gentle to get
into the grain of the leather
and then i'm going to continue this
process throughout the exterior of the
bag so i'm just applying foam cleaner to
the back surface doing one panel at a
time i'm gently massaging the foam into
the grain of the leather
[Music]
this is always important to clean the
bag before applying pigment this will
mean that the pigments will bond to the
leather better if there's anything left
on the surface of the bag such as
silicones from protector sprays or
day-to-day dirt buildup this could
hinder the bonding process
[Music]
now i'm going to clean the interior of
the bag
i just need to clean as much of the
debris away as possible so i'm using a
much more gentle cleaner here which is
like a luxury leather cleaner so it's a
water-based cleaner and i'm basically
just going to gently wipe inside the
lining
this has to be done really gently as if
any pressure is put on or if a product
that was incorrect was used it will then
start to remove even more of the lining
we need to preserve as much of the
original island as possible to make the
job easier in the restoring stage
now we've fully cleaned the bag inside
and out i'm going to move over to the
repair process
the interior of the bag is
disintegrating this is quite common with
this age bag as it was made from a
coated fabric
over time and due to humidity the
surface of the lining will start to
crumble and come away we need to restore
the lining as close to the original as
possible so we're going to rebuild the
surface using fillers and pigments
so here i'm going to use a flexible
filler this filler moves with the
surface of the leather or fabric so i'm
just going to apply this using a very
soft and small paintbrush so i can get a
nice even surface across the whole
interior lining
the idea is to restore the original and
avoid having to replace something like
this this means we retain the original
chanel logo
i'm going to do this very slowly to make
sure that i get a good even coverage all
the way around i'm going to start using
the filler along the top rim and then
work my way down into the main crevices
of the lining once applied this filler
needs 24 hours to cure
now i've left the filler for 24 hours
i'm sanding down the surface so this is
to remove any sort of bits of grain or
lumps or bumps and try and get a smooth
finish i'm just going to start sanding
around the top really gently i'm using a
very fine sandpaper so it doesn't grab
or wear down the surface of the original
lining
and i'm then going to wipe over with
some alcohol
this will remove any of the surface dust
that has been created from the sandpaper
and then it will also slightly soften
the filler to help it smooth and blend
into the original surface of the lining
[Music]
before airbrushing i'm just going to
remove the cc lock hardware this makes
it much easier to get an even coat
around the lock i'm just going to
unscrew this with a small flathead
screwdriver
once i've removed that i'm going to tape
up the remaining hardware on the bag
[Music]
so now i'm just going to move on to
mixing a color for the bag i custom mix
every color by eyes i tend to use about
three or four paints and to mix each
color so here i'm using caramel gold
yellow
and citron
i'm mixing these together and i'm just
going to test the colour on a small area
on the back to make sure it matches this
can take a few attempts sometimes just
to make sure that the colour is
absolutely spot-on
now i've got my colour and i'm good to
go i'm just going to pop it into an
airbrush
if i use airbrushes it allows me to
create lots of fine coats of pigment
rather than painting it on which would
go on too thick
it's really important not to too heavily
coat a bag with paints pigments and
fillers less is always more so we still
want to preserve the original look and
feel of the bag
i'm just going to work my way around
each section of the bag concentrating on
the areas that have more wear
now i've managed to get a nice coat of
pigment
over all of the bag i'm then going to
use a finish
a finish is a clear coat sealant which
goes on top of the pigment to protect it
from wear and tear
here i've mixed about two-thirds high
gloss to the third mat to get a nice
satin sheen which reflects the original
leather
i'm just gonna airbrush this
finish over the whole bag
and then leave it to dry
now moving on to the leather in the
strap i'm actually going to paint this
on with a paintbrush so as not to have
too much wasted paint so i'm just going
to run
all the way along the strap with one
coat leave it to dry and then repeat the
process
i'm then going to finish this off again
with airbrushing the finish for a nice
even layer across the whole strap
now i'm going to move on to the lining
i'm going to take my paint brush and
paint in over all of the areas where the
surface had chipped away
this may take a few coats as it was
shown white underneath but i need to
rebuild the colour back up to match the
surface lining
[Music]
once i've done that i'm going to apply a
finish
due to the severity of the condition of
this lining there will still remain a
few imperfections but what we have done
is we sealed and re-coated the surface
so this will prevent any further damage
from happening and give this handbag a
new lease online
[Music]
now that i've completed all of the
airbrushing i am now going to
polish the hardware
here i'm going to use a fine-grained
metal polish to just gently polish the
surface of the metal this will remove
any of the tarnishing as i'm doing so
you can see the dark colour of the
tarnished metal work coming off onto the
cotton bud
i'm going to polish all the links on the
strap to bring them up to a nice shiny
gold
now all the color work is done i'm going
to reattach the strap
i'm going to firstly re-thread the
leather through the strap
it's really important that you line the
leather up properly so that you get the
same amount each end
i am now using the pliers to reattach
the
chain to the bag now i need to stitch
the leather back together through the
original holes i'm taking some matching
collar thread and using a very fine
needle so i can get through the original
holes
it's really important to go through the
original holes as if you make a new hole
in leather there's no way of reversing
that without then going through another
repair process
i'm just going to secure with a couple
of stitches
and then tie it in on itself to keep it
neat
and now i just need to thread the end
back through the leather and then secure
with a little bit of glue just like it
was originally done so
and now i'm going to apply a leather
protector to the surface of the leather
this will protect the bag from
dye transfer from jeans uv damage and
liquid and oil staining
it's really important to protect your
leather bags for future wear and tear
i'm really happy how the restoration of
this bag turned out the interior is now
ready to be worn and the lining is all
fixed up the outside is no longer
showing any signs of wear and tear and
the gold hardware is looking nice and
shiny i think my customer is going to be
really pleased with the outcome
[Music]
you